hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Chapter one of her work the virtue of
selfishness which is the essay the
Objectivist ethics I'm Rand is going to
set out a sort of to those who know this
sort of thing a rather familiar
hierarchy of being that placed as humans
at the top and miR being or as she calls
it matter at the bottom and has animals
located below human beings and plants
located below them in between matter and
bear being and and animals all of these
are material things but some of them are
living and some of them are conscious
now the reason why she's elaborating
this and we're representing it sort of
schematically in a way that she doesn't
admittedly do within this essay is
because we can see how you move from one
stage to the next and what the
implications of that are from her
philosophical and ethical perspective
which is focused here primarily on two
things one is the notion of survival as
that kind of thing and the other is the
generation
values so let's start out with the
absolute bottom she says that you know
there is such a thing as mere matter and
she even talks about the possibility of
having a indestructible robot who would
be a merely material thing an immortal
indestructible robot an entity which
moves an axe but which cannot be
affected by anything which cannot be
changed which cannot be damaged injured
or destroyed and she says that this kind
of being really couldn't have any values
because it has nothing to gain or lose
nothing could be for or against it it
would have no interest and no goals it's
only living things that can do that
matter is she says is indestructible it
changes its forms it cannot cease to
exist and you know the book for example
or a phone or the chalkboard they don't
care whether they survive or not they
just are what they are it's only living
things that could be said and when we're
talking about plants in a very
metaphorical way even lower animals to
care about whether they continue to
exist but they are self-sustaining
entities they engage in self-sustaining
action to allow themselves to maintain
their their being whatever it happens to
be so she says that an organisms life
now we're talking about plants animals
humans of course bacteria and fungi as
well we can talk about other kingdoms of
life an organisms life depends on two
factors the material or fuel which it
needs from the outside from its physical
background and the action of its own
body the action of using that fuel
properly when she says what standard
determines what is proper in this
context the standard is the organisms
life or what is required for the
organism survival so you know different
kinds of plants and animals and
single-celled organisms and you know
other things whatever other kinds of
life we want to a man
they attempt to maintain themselves in
existence by carrying out their typical
activities that are largely we would say
nowadays the product of their DNA right
so when it comes to plants
she says that plants are really just
engaging in in sort of automate what she
calls automatic physical functions
they're not doing anything consciously
or deliberately she calls these for that
reason simpler organisms they are not
actually conscious they don't feel for
example pleasure and pain they don't
have intentionality of moving towards or
away from things they're just doing
essentially what their programming has
directed them to do so you know we might
say similar things about bacteria we
might say similar things about other
things you know molds and things like
that as well although with bacteria in
some respect they're a little bit more
like animals the interesting thing about
where a virus fits in well virus really
is we're not even sure whether they're
they're qualified as life or not they
they definitely do reproduce so we're
going to leave plants aside we're mostly
interested in her discussion of
conscious being which is animals and
human beings
so she goes on and she says a plant has
no choice of action right it just does
what it does
but higher organisms like animals and
human beings cannot just do automatic
physical functions their needs are more
complex the range of their actions is
wider even if we think about really
low-level animals think about for
example a tick which essentially is a
tick producing factory I mean they do
mate and they suck blood and they suck
blood in
to produce more tics and they really as
far as I understand have only two modes
of sense vibration and heat they're
barely conscious we might say you know
similarly with many other arthropods we
might say there's not a lot going on
there or mollusks you know does an
oyster really engage in much
consciousness not really but it does
engage in some it does respond to its
environment and insofar as they are
mobile at all they're they're making
what we can call choices by a kind of
analogy so she says that the range of
actions required for the survival of
higher organisms is wider it's
proportionate to the range and here
comes a key idea of their consciousness
so here is where she talks about
sensations perceptions and concepts
sensations are the lowest form of
consciousness all of these are involved
in consciousness right not all organisms
go beyond mere sensations but then
there's perceptions and then there's
concepts so let's see what she has to
say about these
she says the lower of the conscious
species possess only the Faculty of
sensation which is sufficient to direct
their action and provide for their needs
a sensation is produced by an automatic
reaction of a sense organ to a stimulus
from the outside world at last for the
duration of the immediate moment as long
as the stimulus lasts and no longer she
calls them an automatic response and
here's an interesting turn of phrase an
automatic form of knowledge now if this
is knowledge it's knowledge in a very
attenuated sense so she says that a
consciousness of this sort can either
seek nor evade them and she goes ahead
and she says an organism that possesses
only the Faculty of sensation is guided
by the pleasure pain mechanism of its
body by and here she says an automatic
knowledge and an automatic code of
values and again we might think about
many of the arthropods you know for
example again ticks although you know we
might be careful in thinking about some
spiders maybe some spiders actually have
perceptions in the way that Rand is
going to talk about it in just a moment
but you know an oyster as well it sucks
in you know whatever it happens to eat
I'm not really that that you know well
read on oyster biology it enjoys that I
guess when it finds something that it
doesn't like you know a little bit of
sand it starts making the pearl around
it so as to not have to feel the thing
that's disturbing it right and all of
these are essentially automatic
processes they're not really that
fundamentally different than those of
plants other than that they have a wider
scope and wider range but then we get to
she says perceptions
she says higher organisms possessed a
much more potent form of consciousness
they possess a Faculty of retaining
sensation so we're talking about memory
here right which is the Faculty of
perception a perception is a group of
sensations automatically retain and
integrated by the brain of a living
organism that gives it the ability to be
aware not of a single stimuli then here
here we have an important transition but
identities of things it can recognize
that sort of thing as that sort of thing
and again this is probably highly
dependent on the kind of organism that
we're talking about so you know when a
spider sees you moving your hand towards
it with its its multiple eyes and
multiple kinds of eyes it's not like the
spider understands well that's a human
being it just understands it as this is
a big thing coming at me and it's kind
of a threat I'd better watch out or I
suppose they'll let you know if I can't
do anything else I'd better bite it and
hope for the best right but you know
think about higher animals such as those
that
make into pets they may have an
incredibly complex array of what here
Rand is calling perceptions or sometimes
she'll also use word percents so when my
cat wakes up in the morning I'll just
use her as an example
she's typically gotten you know my hands
nestled around her and she uses me as
part of her bed and you know lays their
little head on my hands and so there's
probably a percept of comfort and this
is my my person cuz she's very attached
to me and then we get up and I get out
of bed and she stretches herself and you
know goes and gets some water
perceiving water is something that that
is to be drunk and distinguishing
between say water that doesn't taste
good and water that does taste good
that's that's all a matter of percept
that's not mere sensations at this point
and if the water bowl is empty she'll
like look up at me and kind of like you
know hint at me that I should fill it up
there's there's a fairly complex process
going on there
then we go downstairs and you know we'll
get to the head of the stairs and
sometimes she wants me to pick her up so
she doesn't have to climb down herself
she's 17 years old so it's perfectly
understandable and then you know it's
time to feed her and she'll like you
know hop up where the food dish is and
like look over at me like hey dummy
gonna feed me now and as soon as she
like sees me going for the can of her
special kidney food cuz she's an old cat
she's already like attuned alright now
we're gonna get something to eat and the
same thing if it's Caturday and we give
her her fancy feast little portion what
she likes even better these are all
percents and they're part of a complex
dynamic system but it is it is still
rather limited right what what animals
are capable of so she says here an
animal's actions that has percept are
not single distri
responses to singles separate stimuli
but they're directed by an integrated
awareness of the perceptual reality
confronting it it's able to grasp the
perceptual concrete's immediately
present and form automatic perceptual
associations but it can't go any further
so there's limitations here she says
it's able to learn certain skills to
deal with specific situations such as
hunting or hiding which the parents of
the higher animals teach their young but
an animal has no choice in the knowledge
and the skills it acquires it can only
repeat them generation after generation
and they have no choice this is another
really key issue in the standard of
value directing its actions its senses
provided as she says with an automatic
code of values and automatic knowledge
of what is good for it or evil what
benefits are in dangers its life an
animal has no power to extend its
knowledge or to evade it
so we might say you know this this might
need to be made more flexible what about
you know really higher animals going
beyond cats to dolphins or chimpanzees
or things like that but we won't worry
about that right here because what Rand
wants to drive home to us is the fact
that in moving from the merely animal to
the human there is a important
transition that takes place humans are
animals but we're a weird kind of animal
a special kind of animal and she
associates this in part with having what
she calls concepts so she she attributes
this in part and she's not unusual in
this by the way you know you can find
this in the writings of thinkers that
she detest like jean-jacques rousseau
right who talks about this as well
there's there's a certain flexibility to
human being that derives from the fact
that we have fewer instincts and we're
not as controlled by our instincts
the other animals are as a matter of
fact the way she puts it is man has no
automatic code of survival
he has no automatic course of action no
automatic set of values his senses do
not tell him automatically what is good
for him or evil what will benefit his
life or endanger it what goals he should
pursue and what means will achieve them
what values his life depends on his own
consciousness has to discover the
answers to all of his these questions
but his consciousness will not function
automatically so we are placed in a
rather unusual position as a species
we're although you know when it comes to
like do we like the taste of blueberries
you know that sort of thing that's a
matter of sensations and then
perceptions when it comes to all the
other things that really matter like
well I don't know should I eat
blueberries an hour or not you know it's
it's a time for me to go to the lecture
hall and I've got this pail of
blueberries should I bring them along as
a snack or shouldn't I you know even a
chimpanzee doesn't worry about that sort
of thing we do now that's a kind of
silly example but you know we could
multiply many many examples think about
our desire for sexual gratification and
pleasure
you know most animals they handle that
pretty well they're often frustrated but
you know it's pretty clear what they
need to do at what time for us this is
just a mess that we get totally confused
about get all sorts of contradictory
messages and many of us never quite
arrive at a satisfactory way of existing
when it comes just to that matter so
this is quite important the fact that we
we are not as governed by instinct right
what means that we have choices that
means that we are in a certain respect
free in ways that other animals are not
now ran frames this also in terms
what she calls conceptual values derived
from conceptual knowledge she says a
concept is a mental integration of two
or more perceptual concrete's which are
isolated by a process of abstraction and
United by means of a specific definition
so you know book this is 8 what we're
calling here a perception you recognize
this as a book but it's also a concept
book Nesser being a book or something
like that and the word book in language
refers to that concept our use of
concepts as she says is not something
that's hardwired into us like instincts
are and she says that we can you know
take concepts and and create wider and
still wider concepts we can identify and
integrate an unlimited amount of
knowledge and knowledge extending beyond
the immediate perceptions of any given
immediate moment so she says man sense
organs function automatically man's
brain integrates his sense dead in two /
steps automatically but the process of
integrating percepts into concepts this
process is not automatic and so this is
this is quite important because that
means that we have a certain
responsibility here and she's going to
talk about really there's three things
that there's many things that are
determinative of human beings but
there's three things that she's talking
about here that are particularly central
to the way in which human beings are one
of them we've already talked about
language the fact that we can refer to
things and we can do more with our modes
of communication because other animals
communicate too but we can do more of
our modes of communication than they can
the other thing she talks about is
reason and she says reason is the
faculty that identifies and integrates
the material provided by man senses it's
a faculty that we have to exercise by
choice thinking is not an automatic
function focusing one's consciousness is
volitional and so we have another idea
here another actual concept a volition
choice deliberately doing something
because you know thinking is a kind of
doing it's not like thinking and doing a
radically separate from each other so
volition the volitional status of our
consciousness is really central to rands
point of view she says that when a
person unfocused is their mind they may
said to be conscious in a subhuman sense
of the word because they experience
sensations and perceptions but in the
sense of the word applicable to man in
the sense of the consciousness aware of
reality and able to deal with it a
consciousness able to direct the actions
and provide for the survival of the
human being an unfocused mind is not
conscious qua human being it is
conscious qua animal but it's not it's
not fully conscious
so she says consciousness for those
living organisms which possess it is the
basic means of survival for the human
being the basic means of survival is
reason human beings cannot survive as
animals do by the guidance of mere
percept so sensation of hunger will tell
us that we need food but it will not
tell us how to obtain our food and it
will not tell us what food is good for
us or poisonous we this goes on a person
cannot provide for their simplest
physical needs without our process of
thought so this is something that is
really distinctive to us as human beings
this faculty this capacity of reason and
notice she's not saying that reason is
something like an on/off switch that
flips as soon as you go from the animal
to the human or at a certain age like
turning 12 boom now I'm a rational being
it's a continual process that we have to
exercise and I think on this point Rand
is actually saying things that are quite
similar to so many other theorists some
of whom she agrees with like eros
who she thinks is the best ever some of
whom she she denigrates but they're all
they all tended to view things in this
way that rationality is not something
that we can simply take for granted
so distinctively human consciousness for
ein Rand is going to be rational
consciousness and that requires that we
volitionally exercise it
you